hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
in the united states today hedge funds
are buying up entire neighborhoods
outbidding individual buyers by
sometimes up to 50 percent
above the asking price long story short
families in some areas are increasingly
bidding up against
large institutional money questions are
being raised for some
is it fair for wall street and
institutional money to distort a market
like this
and how did the united states get to
this point in the first place
in this episode we'll take a look
usually at a property auction it's a
single house that's up for grabs
but this is starting to change in some
regions
now entire neighborhoods are being sold
to companies
recently 124 homes in texas were sold
for a total of 32 million dollars
the winning bid came from an online
property investing platform
fundrise llc the bid
was 50 over the average asking price for
such properties
this is a microcosm of what is becoming
increasingly more common across the
country
john burns real estate consulting states
that there are over 200 investment firms
getting in
on housing some of these include major
players like jp morgan
and blackrock incorporated by the way
blackrock controls nine trillion dollars
worth of assets
and has a stake in almost every company
in the s p
500 so it's not like blackrock
incorporated is going to have a problem
buying grandma's house down the road
according to the new york times wall
street has thrown roughly 60 billion
dollars to buy up hundreds of thousands
of properties
there's also a trend of home builders
selling their stock directly to
investment firms
for example the home builder lennar corp
will construct
four billion dollars worth of houses and
sell them to investment firms such as
allianz in a venture deal
in all of this there is some concerns
that this is pushing a housing price
recovery
without a home owner recovery
so how did america get here in the first
place
after the housing crisis of 2008
hundreds of thousands of families were
losing their homes
it seemed that prices would keep
dropping with no end in sight
as the years passed the us government
thought that there needed to be some
intervention
in their view there would be terrible
consequences for the economy as a whole
if nothing was done
the government needed more buyers but
who
since mortgages were now hard to obtain
for the average joe and regular
americans were scared away because of
the crisis the government thought that
wall street would be the perfect
candidate for the job
in 2012 they launched a pilot program
that allowed private investors to
purchase the homes of residents
essentially they were artificially
providing demand to a market that had
very little
alright so the problem is solved right
the prices have stopped falling
the economy was saved and empty houses
were now being lived in
well not so fast as is often the case
with wall street
things tend to end up going a little bit
too far
as the atlantic reports between 2011 and
2017
200 000 homes worth a combined 36
billion
were brought up by some of the largest
private equity groups and hedge funds
as mentioned earlier this figure is now
at 60 billion
almost doubling in four years
[Music]
according to dan immigluck a professor
at the urban studies institute at
georgia state university
90 of homes in one arizona zip code were
being bought by institutional investors
today it's gotten to the point where
institutional investors hold at least 20
percent of single-family rentals in some
urban parts of the united states
single-family rental homes may now be a
hot new money maker for wall street
and it goes international an investment
company in qatar
and the korea exchange bank are some
international players that are also
getting in on american housing
with global interest rates so low
investors are looking for higher yields
than they can obtain
in the bond market to add to this
inflation has started to rear its head
and many investment firms see real
estate as a great way to hedge against a
devaluing currency
the rising cost of building materials
such as steel and lumber
also isn't helping the results can end
up in scenarios like the following
there are stories of first home buyers
being outbid on six different houses
often by massive cash offers
in contrast to private mum and dad
landlords these new corporate landlords
are forced to increase returns for their
shareholders
this means aggressive cost cutting and
creating new penalties for renters
they have been a slew of lawsuits
against corporate landlords
unsafe living conditions mold issues
cockroach infestations repeated flat-out
refusals to fix major issues
and unlawful evictions were all part of
these lawsuits
many said that they'd received eviction
notices even though they paid their
rent on time one corporate landlord
american homes for rent began billing
tenants for repairs
after they had moved out they increased
their revenue from these actions by more
than a thousand percent
between 2014 and 2018
it's one of hundreds of complaints about
american homes for rent
the company aims to please investors
what about the tenants
corporate office and buckhead where the
odds of finding an unhappy tenant
are good are you an american homestead
customer i am conor smith says he's been
through
six property managers it's a lot and
still
can't get his ac repaired
he expected more from a company that's
taken in millions of dollars
from wall street investors as the water
was coming up i'm
scooping nancy moss is another american
homes for rent horror story
when her lithonia home backflowed with
raw sewage and when mold started growing
on the walls
her landlord blamed her roughly 14
months that we were in this house we
spent two months in a motel 6.
since moving into their canton home
three years ago
they've had a flood they've had mold
the latest is a thirteen hundred dollar
landscaping bill
for grass that never grew to keep from
being evicted
the adkins paid half i've paid them
seventy four thousand dollars over the
last three years
and this is what we have in return
as this was going on something even
worse started to happen
the investment companies that were
buying up these homes began to
consolidate power
first investment firms began to create
companies to manage their homes
blackstone investments established
innovation homes who was backed by firms
such as blackrock and morgan stanley
colony capital created colony american
homes and then these companies started
merging
in 2015 alone colony american homes
merged with starwood waypoint
residential trust
who itself would merge with the
blackrock-backed innovation homes
american homes for rent which is backed
by investment firms such as vanguard
acquired american residential properties
in a 1.5 billion
deal and by 2017 two major players
controlled nearly 60 of the market
as wall street and these investment
companies continue to acquire more real
estate
they're competing with real people in
some areas such as suburban georgia
renters say that it's difficult to find
properties that aren't
owned by big institutional investors
to some it seems like families will be
forced to stay in institutional rentals
and instead of building wealth they'll
continue to give money to corporations
instead of what would have been
traditionally private citizens
i have to be clear here these
institutional investor companies
don't own enough real estate to drive up
the price of american homes nationwide
but in certain particular areas they are
having a large impact
and currently today investor sales are
up 65
in fort walton florida from a year ago
and 54
in flagstaff arizona and 41 in tulsa
oklahoma
an increasing number of these sales are
coming from wall street
and institutional investors chasing
profits and the money that they can
muster
is limitless in comparison to individual
families
a 2015 study found that institutional
investments are likely to purchase homes
and neighborhoods
where quote fewer residents can qualify
for a mortgage end quote
so the big question is if this trend
keeps going
how will this affect the housing market
will there be an imbalance
are there any risks to the financial
system here
before 2010 institutional landlords
didn't even exist
but now they're showing up in the single
family rental market
in huge numbers so what do you guys
think on the one hand
wall street and institutional investment
provides a pricing flaw for the housing
market
but on the other hand renters may get a
worse deal
if this continues there now may be a
permanent class of renters living under
the ownership of wall street
in the future will we look back at
america and ask
did the us government facilitate a
transfer of wealth from would-be home
owners
to private equity firms in a sense this
is even true today
but the question is how far will this go
so i'm curious do any of you know of any
similar corporate property buying going
on
in any other countries or is this just
an american thing
the best place to discuss this will be
the cold fusion discord
there'll be a new channel made just for
this video i'll leave a link below
anyway if you want to see anything on
business science technology or history
be sure to subscribe to cold fusion my
name is dagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion and
i'll catch you again soon for the next
episode
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
it's me thinking
[Music]
you